[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
chronique et de reportage sur public
sénna on est ensemble du lundi au jeudi
18h 22h pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos invités experts
et voici le sommaire de ce 13 décembre
la commission mixte paritaire elle se
réunira lundi 7 sénateurs 7 députés sous
pression peuvent-ils aboutir à un
compromis sauver le texte immigration
que restera-t-il de l'équilibre
souhaiter initialement par le
gouvernement et puis surtout comment
Emmanuel Macron peut-il redonner de
l'élan à un second quinquena toujours
plus dans l'impasse on répond à ces
questions dans une minute et puis pour
notre second débat c'est un chiffre que
je vous propose le chiffre d'un scandale
118 femmes tuées par leur conjoint ou
ex-conjoint en 2022
en réalité le féminicide n'est pas
seulement un crime individuel c'est un
crime collectif c'est pas seulement le
crime d'un homme c'est le crime d'un
état parce que quand les femmes ne sont
pas protégées dans leur pays respectif
il y a un grave problème
institutionnel pourquoi la France
n'arrive-t-elle pas à mettre fin au
féminicide est-ce un crime d'État un
manque de volonté politique faut-il
inscrire ce terme féminicide dans notre
code pénal pour mieux le combattre le
constat les exemples à suivre en Europe
il y en a et puis les solutions esquissé
en France depuis quelques années tout
cela c'est à découvrir dans TR quart
d'heure mais d'abord donc les contours
de cette commission mixte paritaire très
attendue avec Cécile Siou
Emmanuel Macron l'a dit il veut une loi
immigration avant les fêtes mais pas à
n'importe quel prix si la commission
mixte paritaire ne trouve pas d'accord
lundi le projet sera purement et
simplement abandonné lundi et bien dans
cette commission mix paritaire chacun
sera fait faire de son côté les pas
nécessaires pour arriver à un texte qui
sera peut-être le juste nécessaire au
moins on garde tous les éléments
nécessaires pour qu'il soit efficace tel
que le demandent aujourd'hui les
Français le compte arbourg est donc
lancé pour trouver un compromis
Elisabeth born est désormais à la
manœuvre elle a reçu ce matin à Matignon
les dirigeants de la majorité
sénatoriale avec un objectif tenter de
convaincre les LR de bouger leur lign
rouges à savoir la suppression de l'aide
médicale des et le durcissement de
l'accès à la nationalité mais pour le
centrist HERV Marseille plus mesuré que
la droite sénatoriale rien n'est fait
peut aboutir à un accord
mais les conditions ne sont pas encore
réunies pour qu'il y a un accord parce
que ce sont des sujets qui sont
difficiles et il y a une double
condition c'est de trouver un accord
pour la commission mixte paritaire mais
également un accord susceptible d'être
validé par le Sénat et par l'Assemblée
nationale donc il faut satisfaire les
deux assemblées c'est un exercice
difficile car si un compromis est trouvé
en commission mixte paritaire il doit
être validé par un vote en séance à la
fois par l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat les sénateurs LR qui vont peser
dans la balance continuent de discuter
avec le gouvernement il devrait revoir
ellisabeth borne demain matin et on
analyse cette séquence politique cette
crise ce blocage cet impasse bref tous
ces mots vont être utilisés par nos
invités Christelle crappel bonsoir vous
êtes directrice générale de BVA opinion
Florent vadiillot bonsoir et bienvenue
président du cercle de réflexion l' thée
enseignant à sciencep Jean-Sébastien
Ferjou bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes le
fondateur le directeur d'Atlantico et
Mathieu croissand bonsoir mathieuons
éditorialiste politique bon on va
évidemment beaucoup parler de cette
commission mixte paritaire analyser les
les rapports de force est ce qui peut ou
pas en ressortir mais d'abord peut-être
les effets de cette crise politique dans
l'opinion Christelle crappelet comment
les Français peuvent-ils réagir son
sont-ils en train de réagir ah
probablement qu'ils sont assez perdus
hein je dois dire parce que déjà c'est
assez technique tout ça donc
probablement que c'est assez flou pour
eux tout tous les contours de ce de ces
é là mais ça donne quand même un petit
peu l'image d'un personnel politique
voilà qui qui est dans des querelles un
peu de de Chapell et ça répond pas
forcément à leurs attentes eux voilà que
ce projet là on l'avait vu dans dans
précédentes enquête il l'approuvaient
ils approuvaient la plupart des mesures
donc ils peuvent un peu s'interroger sur
le pourquoi de cette situation
exprimer une forme un peu de lassitude
et ça va sans doute aussi un peu
renforcer peut-être leur méfiance voire
leur agacement à l'égard du du personnel
politique votre avis là-dessus Jean
Sébastien Ferjou est-ce que cet épisode
peut renforcer le rejet de la classe
politique qui s'exprime effectivement
depuis
longtemps B dans à la fois les sondages
et puis le vote des Français
l'abstention qu'on oublie assez vite
après un scrutin je crois qu'il y a deux
récits parallèles sur ce sujet là il y a
le récit que vous venez d'évoquer d'un
projet de loi dont les sondages disent
qu'une majorité de Français le
soutenaent puisque ils sont en attente
de mesures sur l'immigration et il y a
un autre récit qui est aussi est
probablement chez les mêmes français ou
en tout cas une partie des mêmes
français qui consiste à penser que sans
changer de paradigme en quelque sorte
sans changer le système en soit vous
pourrez voter autant de lois que vous
voudrez d'ailleurs on en est à la 20e
loi me semble-t-il depuis 30 ans rien ne
changera vraiment sur l'immigration si
on posait la question dans les sondages
aux Français est-ce que cette loi-là va
selon vous véritablement changer la
situation pour l'immigration dans le
pays je pense qu'une majorité répondrait
non et donc on sa pas exactement ce
qu'il emportera du récit a ou du récit B
après moi j'ai été quand même un peu
perturbé par les éléments de langage du
gouvernement parce que enfin ce qui a
été appliquer ça reste du droit enfin
c'est la Constitution ça reste
l'application aussi de droit
parlementaire et dire que finalement bah
la manière dont ça se joue au Parlement
ça relèverait d'un coup de force ou
d'unun du du déshonneur pour reprendre
un certain nombre de qualificatifs qu'on
a entendu je trouve ça assez inquiétant
de la part de gens qui ne cessent eux de
pointer du doigt des populistes qui sont
censés être démagogues et qui sont
censés être anti-institution ou parce
que ça relève quand même d'une forme
d'antiparlementarisme et ça s'inscrit
quand même dans quelque chose enfin tout
le monde se renvoie cet argument à la
face d'ailleurs he tout le monde
s'accuse d'antiparlementarisme des deux
côtés est-ce que Florent VAD la gauche
est pas en train de devenir le dindon de
la farce de cette de cette histoire on
parlait de la réaction de l'opinion les
électeurs de gauche la la la partie le
le pied gauche de la réforme bon même si
on voyait de moins en moins Olivier du
sopt risque-t-il de disparaître là dans
les dans les jours dans les jours qui
viennent en tout cas il est fort
probable que l'expression une victoire à
la pyus prenne un sens tout à fait amer
pour pour pour la gauche parce que il y
a eu la volonté de de de porter en
quelque sorte un coup symbolique très
fort et de fait il est réussi puisque
depuis début de la semaine c'est l'échec
de géralde
armanin le blocage et cetera donc en
soit la narration politique qui
s'installe elle est très forte et c'est
une une réussite donc le coûp de
stratégie politique stratégie politique
est assez brillant après il y a l'avenir
du texte l'avenir du texte c'est plus
plus quand même plus aléatoire parce que
finalement la gauche est une partie des
écologistes ont renoncé à peser sur un
texte à obliger une commission mixte
paritaire à la conciliation pour tenter
en fait de trouver une ligne de crête et
sauver quelques mesures emblématiques et
donc il y a eu la la stratégie du pire
c'estàd accepter le durcissement
potentiel d'un texte avec une ligne de
crête qui est peut-être échouera-t-il
peut-être n'échouera-t-il pas et donc
finalement avoir à la fin mais ça veut
dire qu'ils pourront plus le faire
pardon nous interrompe là dans cette
commission mixte paritaire qui qui
s'annonce la gauche ne pourra pas peser
sans doute maématiquement la gauche ou
la partie ou l'il gauche de la
majoritétimativement je vois pas comment
en fait avec une droite sénatoriale même
talonné par les centristes euh des
députés macronistes dont on pense qu'ils
ne vont pas partir en dissident sur ce
texte-là je vois mal Sacha Houlier
partir en dissidence sur ce texteel même
s'il a fait beaucoup de politique à
partir de cela et des du rassemblement
national et des députés LR je vois mal
comment en fait la gauche je pourrait
réellement peser dans un dispositif où
elle est ultra minoritaire et surtout
avec une période de préparation
extraordinairement restinte ça revenir
sur les conditions d'organisation de
cette c juste sur la déconnexion avec
les Français euh peut remarquer quand
même que sur l'année les deux gros quaks
parlementaire la la réforme des
retraites avec le 493 et ce qui s'est
passé hier ne répondent pas au ve des
Français euh le pour la réforme des
retraite ils n'en voulaiit pas ils l'ont
eu euh la réforme de l'immigration ils
la voulait ils l'ont pas h donc c'est
quand même au final au bout du bout du
bout quel que soit le récit qui s'impose
je veux dire ça état parce que bah là
aujourd'hui il on verra mais pour
l'instant il pas les gens se disent
tiens si on l'a pas le 12 décembre c'est
très très grave plutôt que si on l'a le
20 ou le ça ça j'entends bien mais pour
l'instant le signal le signal qu'envoie
les le le Parlement et l'assemblée
notamment c'est de déconnexion profonde
avec les aspirations des Français et
donc ça pose cette question la
commission mixte paritaire effectivement
ça passe peut-être un peu au-dessus de
d'une partie de l'opinion mais sauf
qu'il y a une
acculturation au terme et à la vie
parlementaire et ça on ne peut que s'en
réjouir évidemment elle se réunit lundi
objectif construire un compromis en tout
cas c'est ce que souhaite la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale on l'écoute
l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de réunir ce
qu'on appelle cette fameuse commission
mixte paritaire députés sénateur se
députés se sénateurs commission où
personne aujourd'hui n'a la majorité
donc il faut et c'est l'esprit et
l'essence d'une commission mixte par
il faut trouver un compromis pour faire
un compromis il faut que chacun fasse un
pas vers l'autre nous espérons que ça
sera le cas parce que il faut sortir des
postures les Français et nous avons
besoin de ce texte nous avons besoin de
d'assouplir nos procédures de les
accélérer de mieux traiter l'asile elle
va se dérouler sous pression Florent
vadiillo puisqueil y a d'abord la date
dès lundi ensuite ça a été annoncé si
elle n'est pas conclusive c'est le terme
employé c'est s'il y a pas d'accord de
compromis le texte tirer c'est ce qu'a
d'ors et déjà dit le le le gouvernement
est-ce qu'on peut sereinement travailler
sous cette pression quand on est
parlementaire d'abord il vaut mieux
retirer un texte puisque après une
commission mixte paritaire le dernier
mot est à l'Assemblée nationale et les
mêmes causes produisant les mêmes effets
je pense qu' il y a deux concessions la
première c'est la date puisque Sacha
aoulier voulait une réunion rapide il a
obtenu le Sénat était pour janvier donc
je pense que on a donné un peu de de
sucre à à Sacha Houlier la deuxième
concession effectivement c'est
d'annoncer que en cas de non conclusif
il y aura pas de 49 et ça c'est quand
même ça n'est pas neutre et donc en
réalité la pression je pense qu'elle est
beaucoup plus sur les députés de la
majorité qui serait la majorité
Renaissance qui serait beaucoup plus
enclin à à tenter un coup dans le secret
de la CMP puisque il faut rappeler qu'il
n'y a pas il y a un contre-rendu assez
succin de la commission mixte paritaire
il n'y a pas le gouvernement présent et
il y a quasiment personne pour assister
au débat donc je pense que tout a été
fait pour signaler au députés de la
majorité que une une un coup politique
aurait des conséquences extrêmement
lourdes sur le le le destin donc c'est
en fait une une CMP sous pression mais
uniquement pour ceux qui sont dissipés
pour la droite euh sénatoriale ou
Assemblée nationale pour le
rassemblement national c'est plutôt du
petit lait parce que le texte qui
servira de base de discussion c'est le
texte du Sénat puisque seul le texte
issu de la commission des lois donc
quand même assez tronqué par la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale ne peut pas servir de de
référence donc moi je pense que voilà
c'est c'est une une pression quand même
assez unilatérale h alors justement sur
ce que ce qu'on attendent les sénateurs
LR je vous propose un témoignage une
réaction pour être plus précis celle de
la sénatrice des Alpe maritime Dominique
estroszi ça sonne les lignes rouges on
va réemployer ces termeslà posés par les
sénateurs LR je pense que le texte qui a
été voté ici au Sénat répond à la
volonté aux attentes des Français parce
qu'il s'agit d'un texte qui est
équilibré et cet équilibre nous ne
voulons pas qu'il y soit porté atteinte
si ce n'est bien sûr parce qu'on sait
très bien comment cela se passe en
commission mixte paritaire qu'il y ait
quand même des points qui puissent être
amodiés amendés mais à 98 % rester sur
le texte voté ici au Sénat je répète ma
question sur l'aide médicale d'État
est-ce que vous allez accepter
d'abandonner à cette mesure à cet
instant l'aide médicale d'État fait
partie des lignes rouges qui ont été
votées ici au Sénat par les 2/ers de
l'Assemblée
sénatoriale Alexandre Poussard qui est
partout aujourd'hui vous étiez aux
questions au gouvernement c'est viens de
vous voir face à Dominique ça sonne et
donc vous allez nous expliquer ce que
contient le texte immigration dans sa
version sénatoriale effectivement Thomas
alors d'abord parlons d'une mesure dont
on a beaucoup parlé la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papierers dans les
métiers en tension le texte initial du
gouvernement prévoyait une
régularisation quasiment automatique de
ces travailleurs la majorité de droite
et du centre du Sénat n'acceptait pas
cette mesure qu'elle a modifié en
prévoyant que ces régularisations se
fassent uniquement au cas par cas selon
le pouvoir 10 discrétionnaire du préfet
et après un contrôle de critères très
strict de chaque dossier des
travailleurs sans papier en commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale et
bien les députés Renaissance ont un peu
gardé la version du Sénat mais en
assouplissant les critères de contrôle
strict du préfet donc sur cette mesure
là il peut y avoir un compromis lundi en
commission mixte paritaire alors il y a
une autre mesure et là peut-être que
c'est un peu plus compliqué l'aide
médicale d'État ah oui ça c'est une
mesure qui coince entre la majorité
présidentielle et euh la droite
sénatoriale on le rappelle hein la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
a voté une réforme de l'aide médicale
d'État qui finance les soins des
étrangers en situation irrégulière et
ils ont transformé cette ame en Amu aide
médicale d'urgence avec un panier de
soins restreint cette dernière
modification et bien elle est
inacceptable pour la majorité
présidentielle la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée a supprimé euh cette mesure
du texte immigration et pour l'instant
euh ce qu'on peut et bien entendre de la
part des sénateurs républicains c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas prêts à revenir sur
cette restriction de l'aide médicale
d'État mais le gouvernement propose une
voie de passage sur ce point pour
trouver un compromis on va écouter Hervé
Marseille le président des sénateurs
centristes qui était avec ellisabeth bne
ce midi l'aide médicale d'État peut
faire l'objet la première ministre
l'avait déjà annoncé un accord à partir
d'un texte qui serait discuté au mois de
janvier
donc on dit que c'est un cavalier
législatif on peut le sortir du texte
immigration et en faire un un
texte qui soit un texte différent mais
au tout début de
l'année Alexandre quelles sont les les
autres mesures qui ont été rajoutées par
la droite et le centre ici au Sénat qui
pourrai justement être des points de
blocage dans cette négociation on av
bien compris ce qui est en train de se
jouer entre les LR et les renaissances
oui sur ces mesures on en parle moins
mais les sénateurs ont voté d'autres
durcissements de ce projet de loi
immigration ils ont par exemple prévu
que le Parlement puisse fixer des quotas
d'immigration chaque année que certaines
aides sociales des étrangers soient
conditionné à au moins 5 ans de
résidence régulière en France pour 6
mois actuellement ça c'est une vraine
ligne rouge he cette deuxème mesure pour
le gouvernement tout comme le
durcissement de l'accès à la nationalité
le durcissement du droit du sol c'est là
où ça coince dans la négociation et puis
on le rappelle les sénateurs ont
également réintroduit le délit de séjour
irrégulier qui avait été supprimé par
François Hollande en 2012 et ils ont
prévu que pour les personnes qui sont
sous occup qtf obligation de quitter le
territoire français et bien elle n'it
pas le droit à un hébergement d'urgence
toutes ces mesures du Sénat elles ont
été supprimées par les députés
Renaissance en commission des lois à
l'Assemblée nationale ça veut donc dire
qu'on est encore assez loin d'un accord
entre la majorité présidentielle et les
républicains merci beaucoup Alexandre
Poussard pour toutes ces explications
Christel C je je reviens vers vous sur
la la façon dont les Français jugeaient
non pas la version sénatorale mais la
version initiale de de de la réforme
proposée par le gouvernement cette
espèce cet équilibre pas de cette espèce
cet équilibre qui était voulu par par
l'exécutif et incarné on l'a dit
plusieurs fois ici par deux ministres
Géral armanin et Olivier duopt est-ce
qu'ils approuvaient que cette réforme
marche sur ces deux jambes d'une
certaine façon bah oui tout à fait nous
on avait fait une enquête au au au mois
de mai et on avait testé un certain
nombre de mesures qui allaient voilà
être qui allait être discuté et ils
étaient très largement d'accord pour par
exemple les mesures les plus dures le
fait de facile l'expulsion des étrangers
en cas de CRIM et délit mais cette
fameuse mesure de régulariser les
travailleurs sans papis dans les
secteurs en tension on recueillit aussi
un un inentiment très majoritaire 68 %
donc on était sur des mesures qui
finalement étaient presque consensuelles
aussi bien celles qui étaient plus dur
que celles qui était plus en faveur des
immigrés et ça avait l'air de traduire
finalement une forme de en même temps
qui satisfaisait en tout cas la majorité
des ça c'était vrai quand la réforme a
été lancée est-ce que c'est resté cette
espèce
d'équilibre dans dans les enquêtes
d'opinion en tout cas au fur à mesure
que justement on voyait d'autres
versions du texte sortir notamment celle
du Sénat il y a toujours eu une forme de
pragmatisme quand même sur ces questions
là alors oui sur un certain nombre
d'opinions peut-être que les les choses
se sont durcies notamment à la faveur du
du contexte aussi beaucoup plus
sécuritaire et des des voilà du contexte
un peu anxiogène malheureusement de ces
derniers temps mais sur les travailleurs
sans papiier une forme de pragmatisme
aussi de beaucoup de gens qui se disent
ben ils sont là ils travaillent ils sont
là depuis longtemps c'est serait aussi
normal de les régulariser on n pas vu
forcément de basculement sur sur ce
pointl Florent vadiillot justement votre
avis sur les l'équilibre du alors là on
peut parler du fond et je voudrais bien
vous entendre les uns et les autres sur
sur le le le fond est-ce que les
Français sont pas un peu moins
idéologues que que leur représentant
politique quand il s'agit de parler
d'immigration vous voyez ce que je veux
dire en radio j'entends d'abord je pense
que il y a on pourrait se poser des
question sur la manière dont les
Français ont été consultés sondés et si
c'est représentatif d'une ligne de
clivage si le débat a été correctement
conduit si tous les toutes les
informations ont été données donc je
reste assez prudent sur le le le
pragmatisme des Français parce que quand
on sort l'aide médicale d'urgence quand
on sort les travailleurs le travailleur
les métiers senstion ça reste quand même
deux éléments du texte qui sont certes
très emblématiques mais qui ne
représentent pas l'intégralité du texte
qui va quand même très loin ça c'est
c'est le premier élément le deième
élément je pense que il y a quand même
un rabot constitutionnel qui risque de
passer si le texte venait être adopté h
h parcecoup de disposition son
extrmement problémati la question par du
conditionnement des aides sociales à 50
présen sur le territoire national c'est
un vrai sujet de rupture d'égalité
devant la loi donc je suis même pas
certain si vous voulez que l'ensemble du
texte en l'état tourne
constitutionnellement et et puisse
passer le cap d'une censure donc avant
de savoir en fait ce qui sera
définitivement mis en application et ce
que les Français pourront apprécier ou
pas comme pas je reste assez prudent
ouis Jean séastien vous disiez tout à
l'heure on sait pas les Français ils
approu peut-être le texte mais il y a
aussi une lcitude ou une lucidité face à
ce qu'il pourrait vraiment changer pour
notre PRS mais quand même on dit souvent
qu'il y a une demande de d'ordre de
régalien sur ces questions d'immigration
mais il y a aussi une forme de lucidité
face à des secteurs d'activité qui tout
simplement ne tournerai plus aujourd'hui
en France sans travailleurs é d'origine
étrangère ou étranger avec ou sans
papier mais bien sûr mais c'est pas
uniquement de la lucidité sur les omie
parce que je suis pas certain d'ailleurs
que ce soit une très grande lucidité en
matière d'économie quand vous regardez
l'état de l'économie en réalité il y a
déjà trop de travailleurs par rapport à
ce qui est l'évolution de la
productivité française donc on va plutôt
vers des suppressions massives d'emploi
si on se projette à 2 ans que vers un
besoin de main d'œuvre faut pas
confondre le fait que certains secteur
et de la peine à recruter pour des
raisons qui ont plus à voir avec les
conditions d'organisation du marché du
travail qu'avec l'immigration en soi et
le destin économique de la France après
on en revient et c'est exactement ce qui
vient d'être exprimé à l'instant c'est
de toute façon je pense que toute une
partie des Français ont compris que peu
importe ce qui était ou pas dans ce
projet de loi à l'arrivée on leur
expliquera que le Conseil le Conseil
constitutionnel ou x juridiction
s'oppose à la souveraineté finalement
des Français en matière migato ça là
aussi vous disiez on est dans le dans
dans l'application du droit avec la
motion de rejet on sera aussi dans au
combien dans l'appliation drit
absolument mais en l'état actuel du
droit il faut respecter ce qu'est le
droit actuel on peut aussi concevoir
qu'il y a une offre politique qui
consiste à dire ne renonçons pas à
l'état de droit mais à l'état du droit
ce qui est pas quand même exactement la
même chose et je pense que ce sentiment
de dépossession regardez le débat qui a
lieu au Royaume-Uni à l'heure actuelle
et pourtant ils sont sortis l'Union
européenne c'est pour ça je pense que ça
n'a pas strictement à voir c'est pas un
discours pro ou anti-européen ce que la
crise politique qui se noue là par
rapport aux accords que le Royaume-Uni
veut signer avec le Rwanda pour que les
demandeurs d'asile soient au Rwanda
pendant que leurs dossiers sont traités
ces crises politiques là elles existent
partout le sujet c'est que et le droit
ne peut pas régler à lui seul les
questions migratoires mais quand même le
le sujet c'est que les Français et les
citoyens des démocraties occidentales de
manière plus générale se sonentent
dépossédés de leur souveraineté
migratoire ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi les magistrats du Conseil
constitutionnel ou ceux de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme devrai
décider regardez tous les cas qu'on a vu
ces derniers jours et Géral armendan
aurait dû se poser la question voyant
les tweets d'Éric chti lundi matin vous
avez vu avec ce jeune oubeek me
semble-t-il à qui enfin le Conseil qui a
été expulsé et le Conseil d'État veut
imposer à la France le fait de le
ramener ça ce qui se produira
certainement jamais mais ce ce sentiment
là que des magistrats se substituent à
la volonté souveraine des citoyens en
matière migratoire on peut ne on peut ne
pas partager leurs préoccupations c'est
encore un autre débat mais personne ne
peier qu'il est structurant dans le
débat politique FL va dire est-ce que ça
accentue le rejet des de de la classe
politique par les Français dont on
parlait tout à l'heure ce sentiment que
de toute façon même si on a un
gouvernement une majorité ou une
majorité qui essaie d'imposer un texte
de toute façon il y aura toujours des
magistrats pour pour empêcher de
l'appliquer je suis pas certain que tout
le monde connaisse différents degrés de
juridiction et que les magistrats soient
l'alpha et l'oméga de non mais il y a
souvent des faits d'actualité qui
cristallise effectivement ce sentiment
ce qui est certain c'est que l'idée que
la politique est devenue impuissante et
que elle n'est que du bavardage et
désormais je crois extrêmement bien
installé et que ça n'est pas uniquement
la faute des magistrats mais c'est aussi
l'incapacitéit pas c'est la faute
magistrat les magistat c'est un débat
mais en tout cas à tous les échelons
politiques il y a la question de savoir
à quel quel moment les promesses sont
transformées en fait à quel moment la
vie des gens change concrètement je
pense qu'il y a pas que l'immigration en
la matière qui pose cette question là
donc oui la question de de la capacité
de performativité de la vie politique
elle est réellement posée et c'est pour
ça que cette législature là à
l'Assemblée nationale elle a des
conséquences particulières parce que la
forme de politique spectacle à contf en
permanence elle continue à mon sens
d'abîmer le fait que la politique ça
n'est pas uniquement des débats
enflammés qui ne finiss sur rien ça doit
être aussi la vie des gens qui qu' qui
se change de manière considérable et
réelle au regard de la crise que l'on
traverse donc je reste extrêmement
dubitatif à l'égard de la stratégie des
groupes politiques à l'Assemblée
nationale qui corrobore ce sentiment
diffus que la politique c'est beaucoup
de verbes et peu d'action et et aussi
sur les sur la la comme au cas par cas
moi je ne comprends pas la logique qui
est celle du ministre l'intérieur de
vous regardez son fil Twitter tous les
jours il vous explique il a expulsé je
sais pas qui fait des listes de noms
mais le sujet n'est pas de savoir c'est
une façon de dire je fais et justement
je su pas que dansunation j'ai bien
compris mais voz bien sais que vous
l'aviez compris mais la question qui se
joue derrière c'est pouvons-nous le
faire à environnement juridique égal ou
avons-nous besoin de changer les lois à
un moment il faut quand même traduire la
responsabilité des hommes politiques
c'est pas juste c'est quand même
l'articulation entre l'action et le
discours et le discours sur les
changements de loi dont nous avons
besoin ou pas mais quand finalement on
renonce aux un parce que le discours
politique se concentre plus sur de la
symbolique ou de l'émotionnelle et que
dans l'action on est juste un peu dans
des moulinets en quelque sorte de dire
bah oui s'il faut tordre le bras ici du
enfin des juges je vais le faire mais on
vous voyez bien que ce grand écart là il
n'est pas satisfaisant d'un point de vue
démocratique Matth j'aais vous entendre
sur le revenons au point de départ de
cette de cette réforme incarnée par deux
ministres du Géral je disais tout à
l'heure est-ce que c'était un leur
politique ou quand même un objectif
réaliste comment le comment
l'exécutif le
percevait ça s'est fracassé sur un ça se
voulait malin se voulait très très malin
l'idée c'était de de diviser les
oppositions en faisant vous savez déjà
la loi a été présentée quand même façon
politique pour les nuls Avec ce slogan
on va être gentil avec les gentils
méchants avec les méchants quand vous
expliquez aux gens la politique pour les
nuls ben
généralement c'est pas une façon de de
de bien les respecter
ensuite on leur a dit bah on on va faire
un truc très malin on va faire voer les
mesures les plus dures sur l'immigration
par la droite et les mesures les plus
favorables pour l'inté tion par la
gauche avec cette idée on va vendre
quelque chose qui était en même temps
tout ça a été pensé hein très voulu
c'est super malin comme ça on parle à
tout le monde c'était le début faut se
souvenir qu'on est à ce momentl à
l'automne 2022 euh et cette majorité
cette assemblée sans majorité en est à
ses débuts éisabeth borne dit qu'on va
vendre des majorités de projets là il y
a deux projets dans un projet c'est
vraiment la chapelle six de de de la
politique macronienne et en fait
qu'est-ce qui se passe ben ça n'a pas
divisé les opposants ça a fédéré les
opposants ça a additionné les
mécontentements et ça ce qui est assz ce
qui est assez curieux c'est qu'ils vont
se rendre compte assez vite il y avait
Géral armanin qui qui incarnait le volet
répressif et puis Olivier dusop qui
était chargé d'incarnet vol les gentil
sauf que Olivier duop passe dans le camp
des méchants avec la réforme des
retraites il est plus du tout considéré
comme un gentil et puis euh et puis
surtout il y a il y a quand même des
interrogations souvenez-vous après la la
réforme des retraites on se dit est-ce
qu'on enterre ce projet ou pas est-ce
qu'on le traduit juste par des décrets
d'application et pas on n fait pas une
loi est-ce qu'on fait deux textes et pas
un et puis faut rappeler que Gérard
Larcher le président du Sénat a dit non
il faut un grand texte une grande loi
qui contient tout ça et donc petit à
petit ça va ça va prendre comme ça et et
Géral armanin en décidant que le débat
commence au Sénat en première lecture va
Diler avec la droite et donc ça va
déséquilibrer considérablement le texte
ent-etemps Olivier duopte aura disparu
des écrans radar et puis ce volet
intégration va réapparaître par petit
bout dans la discussion à l'Assemblée en
gros quand vous dites aux gens on va on
va on va faire un texte de droite avec
la droite au Sénat puis après non on va
quand même remettre un peu de gauche
assemblée ben tout le monde se sent pris
pour pour desendives audelà de l'échec
de de c'est pas tant l'échec de la
méthode d'armanin on peut contester sa
stratégie je pense qu'il a été très
maladroit vis-à-vis de LR notamment mais
c'est l'écheac de la méthode Macron que
les débauchages individuels plutôt que
les accords politiques bah ça ne marche
pas alors est-ce que c'est la fin du en
même temps effectivement ou de la
stratégie d'Emmanuel Macron on va en
débattre rapidement d'abord je vous
propose d'entendre la réaction du
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
Patrick caner qui lui parlait C
l'après-midi de fiasco c'est un
fiasco depuis 2022 le président de la
République subit une crise
institutionnelle vous venez d'y ajouter
une crise politique majeure et inédite
en jouant sur les peurs le président de
la République attise les braises d'un
pays déjà incandescent
oui c'est irresponsable votre Ministre
aux déclaration à géométrie variable a
pris sur lui l'entière charge du projet
de loi immigration il a échoué au
travers de son échec vous avez échoué et
au travers de votre échec c'est le
président de la République qui a échoué
à vouloir tromper tout le monde vous
n'avez convaincu personne vous avez
provoqué cette situation c'est à vous de
nous en sortir désormais mais puisque
vous écartez un nouvel article 49 alinéa
3 quelle sera l'ampleur de la
capitulation de la majorité
présidentielle en commission mixte
paritaire quel sera le prix du
renoncement au
républicaine le en même temps macronien
vient-il de se fracasser sur le mur de
l'immigration Florent vadiillot je
redonne la parole à J bien Ferjou juste
après oui et non plutôt non parce mê
temps écoutez je vais être normand plus
que macronien mais ce que vous disiez
Mathieu Cando est très juste c'estd que
il y avait la volonté d'avoir deux
textes ce qui a été fait pour le
nucléaire on oublie que le nucléaire
c'est passé vraiment très facilement à
l'Assemblée parce qu'il y a eu une
proposition loi avec les communistes qui
a été acceptée par le gouvernement et
puis un TEX qui est passé comme ça et
donc finalement on a été gentil avec les
gentils et méchants avec les méchants et
donc tout le monde pouvait dire qu'il
avait trouvé lorsque Gérard Larché a
imposé un texte unique et que le
gouvernement y a cédé il a en fait
obligé le macronisme à échouer sur ce
texte là et parce que les deux n'était
pas conciliable donc ça n'est pas tant
la fin du macronisme du gentil avec les
gentils méchants avec les méchants que
l'échec d'une stratégie politique de
négociation avec la droite sénatoriale
et donc la question qui que moi je n'ai
pas pour laquelle je n'ai pas de réponse
c'est est-ce que le Sénat va continuer à
pousser le gouvernement à l'échec et en
en empêchant en réalité tout
échappatoire politique ou est-ce que il
va donner un peu d'oxygène au président
de la République pour l'instant c'est
plutôt la privation d'oxygène qui semble
stratégie et on va parler des des
options pour Emmanuel Macron dans un
instant Jean-Sébastien Ferjou vous ai
interrompu vouliez développer peut-être
vos votre démonstration oui mais je
pense que c'est vraiment la fin enfin
qui était déjà en Comat avancé hein en
même temps en réalité et encore plus
dans la mesure où depuis 2022 il y a pas
de majorité absolue c'était un mais il y
a beaucoup de textes qui ont été votés
alors ils étaient moins médiatiques que
ceuxa mais il y a beaucoup de textes qui
ont été votés mêmevec une ma politiqu
sur les sujets politiques qui sont au
cœur du débat public que ce soit la
sécurité que ce soit l'immigration que
ce soit je sais pas peut-être
l'éducation même on voit bien que le en
même temps ne peut pas marcher le
macronist ça a été la négation de la
politique c'était de dire finalement on
s'en fiche de la droite et de la gauche
ça c'est un truc pour l'ancien monde
nous on est des startupers on s'inspire
de minseay et ou de la Cour des comptes
ou de minseay en train de pomper les
rapports de la Cour des comptes parce
que c'est aussi pour ça qu'on P main sa
parfois et nous serons bien meilleurs
que tous ces gens qui auparavant
prenaient la peine d'aller voir des
électeurs et de se faire élire mais non
la réalité c'est que ça ne marche pas
parce que vous avez des sujets ça n'a
aucun sens de résumer les choses à
gentil avec les gentils méchants avec
les méchants enfin je dire les électeurs
de droite ne sont pas des méchants qui
voudraient faire du mal aux immigrés ou
pas plus que les électeurs de gauche ne
seraiit que des Gentils qui leur
voudrait que du bien quand vous voyez
qu'il y a des rapports de force à 80 %
on voit bien que la réalité est plus
complexe simplement faut revenir à la
politique et ce qu'on voit là je pense
mais aussi parce que mécaniquement on
arrive à la fin du macronisme il va y
avoir 2027 c'est que le clivage gauche
droite est aussi en train de revenir
malheureusement les partis de droite
comme de gauche ont de la peine à y
donner de la consistance ça c'est un
autre sujet mais il faut pas confondre
les deux il y a l'échec de la méthode
Macron et je vous disais qui était sur
du débauchage individuel du débauchage
individuel vous dites la fin du
macronisme mais il reste quand même 3
ans comment mais juste juste parler au
bout un accord avec François Baayou
c'est un accord politique ça permet
certainement Emmanuel Macron de gagner
mais c'est un vrai accord politique
c'est un accord de gouvernement chacun
met quelque chose dans le panier commun
géralin Ouard Philipp ce sont juste des
trahisons et d'ailleurs la preuve c'est
que derrière quand ils sont chargés de
eux aller faire du débauchage auprès de
leur famille politique ça ne marche que
chez les déjà convaincus j'ai envie de
vous dire ceux de droite qui ont envie
d'être ministre d'Emmanuel Macron ils
ont pas besoin de passer par la ce
d'Arman il y a quand même encore une
partie un socle de soutien à Emmanuel
Macron qui est réel qui bougecoup qui
est d'un tiers alors qu'il était plutôt
de 40 % avant la réforme des retrait
donc il a quand même per
dires pas réussi àavoir mais c'est vrai
que ça interroge sur la suite parce que
il y a quand même une partie d'électeurs
qui vienent de la gauche qui qui ont
soutenu voilà Emmanuel Macron et sur un
texte comme l'immigration sur ces la
question plus des des valeurs peut-être
si le texte est vraiment très à droite
on peut s'interroger quand même sur le
fait que ces gens-là continuent voilà à
accorder leur soutien surtout dans la
perspective effectivement de 2027 où il
y aura peut-être plus une figure aussi
centrale qui l'incarnera alors on a
titré ce ce débat le quinquena Macron
dans dans l'impasse avec un point
d'interrogation la première partie on a
on a fait le constat de la passe
maintenant m on va essayer de voir
quelle carte le président a dans son jeu
comment peut-il sortir de cette crise
ben d'abord en se montrant lucide sur la
nature et la portée de ce qui s'est
passé lundi soir avec ce vote ce qui
revient au fond à se poser une question
est-ce que c'était une péripétie
parlementaire de plus dans cette
assemblée sans majorité ou est-ce que
c'était le début d'autres choses lundi
soir tout le monde était sonné au sommet
de l'État sonné de voir au tapis un des
projets phar du ququena sonn de voir
cette coalition disparate des
oppositions l'emporter sonn de pas avoir
vraiment vu le coup venir et passer le
choc et la colère Emmanuel Macron a
toutefois décidé de faire le Doron Géral
Darmanin des avoués ben il est maintenu
le texte euh pardon le texte retoqué il
poursuivra son cheminement législatif
dans une commission mixte paritaire et
puis on navigue un peu entre le même pas
mal et circuler il y a rien à voir hier
soir le président a redit à ses
ministres qu'il avait réuni allit disait
que l'essentiel c'est de tourner la page
de clore la séquence comme on dit chez
les communiquants qu'elle soit positive
ou non donc il y a même un échec du
texte envisagé puisquil y aura pas de
493 comme si au fond tout ça n'était pas
bien grave est-ce que c'est une erreur
oui parce que quelque chose à mon avis a
changé dans le vote de lundi soir en
additionnant leur voix pour refuser
d'examiner le texte les députés des
oppositions ils ont fait fi de leur
fonction c'est de leur job de député de
leur conviction parfois et de leur
prévention à voter ensemble pourquoi
pour se payer Gérald armanin et Emmanuel
Macron et ça a marché en un vote ils ont
retoqué un texte mis à jour les impasses
du en même temps comme le disait tout à
l'heure jeansébastien et puis euh ils
ont fragilisé le pouvoir donc ce je vois
pas comment le vu le niveau
d'antagonisme la volonté de revanche et
la déessation personnelle que certains
nourrissent à l'encontre du président je
vois pas ce qu'il est retiendrait de
recommencer à chaque occasion qui se
présentera dans le futur la possibilité
donc forte qu' 'agiss pas juste d'un
accident de la vie parlementaire et bien
d'une stratégie de blocage et
d'empêchement dont on aurait vu la forme
une première étape lundi soir et
l'Élysée serait bien inspiré de tirer
les leçons plutôt que de dire en gros
rien ne change on continue comme avant
allez on se projette un peu dans
l'avenir de de quel levier dispose le
président mais jusqu'ici le président de
la République il s'est échiné à tenté de
compenser son absence de majorité en
inventant des machins et des bidules
comme le Conseil national de la
refondation comme les entretiens de de
Saint-Denis ou encore se rendre
rendez-vous avec la nation qui était
promis juste avant le bug à l'Assemblée
lundi soir qui est promis pour le pour
le mois de janvier par le président
alors qu'il dispose pourtant de levier
que lui confèrent nos institutions
l'élargissement de la majorité pour
trouver les 40 voix qui lui manquent ce
qui supposerait un accord d'appareil
avec les LR et donc une forme de
cohabitation ça c'est plaide pour l'idée
d'un d'un remanement malheureusement ça
n'a pas fonctionné jusqu'à présent
dissolution au risque de perdre encore
un peu plus de sièges sans garantie que
l'Assemblée en ressorte plus gouvernable
on voit bien un peu le la difficulté ou
encore un autre un autre outil que
confère nos institutions le référendum
pour se relégitimer sur une question
avec le danger comme on dit
traditionnellement que les Français
répondent pas à la question mais plutôt
à à celui qui la pose bref on on le voit
il y a des outils qu' n'utilisent pas il
en invent d'autres euh ce qui explique
en gros que tous ces choix hasardeux
fabriquent cette cette hésitation du
moment alors je voudrais qu'on se
concentre sur le l'hypothèse d'une
dissolution pour l'instant elle est
clairement rejetée par le Président de
la République on écoute sur ce thème la
ministre des Solidarités des famille
elle était sur Sud Radio ce matin Aurore
berger je crois qu'il y a aucune raison
aujourd'hui de de dissoudre l'Assemblée
nationale on a certes une majorité
relative mais il y a pas de majorité
alternative qui existe la seule majorité
alternative c'est une arithmétique une
addition qui fait qu'il faut que toutes
les oppositions s'allient mais est-ce
que ça veut dire qu'elles ont toutes le
même projet à porter je crois pas je
crois pas que les électeurs tant ici de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon que de Marine Le Pen
que des républicains du Parti socialiste
pensent ou veulent la même chose donc il
y a pas de majorité alternative c'est
aussi la démonstration de ces dernières
ures la dissolution on va faire un peu
de de politique fiction on va voir
combien de temps ça ça reste de la
politique fiction Christelle gra si on
votait dimanche qui est-ce que le RN
parce que c'est ce queon entend
régulièrement en sortirait forcément
gagnant al forcément gagnant on peut pas
savoir c'est clair que dans les études
d'opinion il il apparaît quand même très
souvent comme le gagnant d'un certain
nombre de séquences voilà son image
s'est considérablement amélior
donc il a voilà il est quand même en
position de force après ça reste une
élection serait une élection législative
à laquelle les gens votent pas forcément
donc il y aurait quand même toute cette
question de l'abstention est-ce que ça
remobiliserait pas sûr et est-ce que ça
donnerait une vraie majorité c'est pas
sûr non plus c'est même plutôt l'inverse
qui est certain sera pe-être encore
moins gouvernable après quoi donc ça
n'arrangerait peut-être pas du tout la
situation et effectivement d'un point de
vue du point de vue de Renaissance au
regard des données qu'on peut avoir on
peut penser qu'ils auraient peut-être
moins de de voix ou de déput
oui parce que en réalité on ne peut pas
regarder les sondages au niveau national
pour une élection législative il faut
regarder 577 circonscriptions je vous
invite à lire un article très
intéressant publié sur Atlantico ce
matin parce que nous travaillons très
régulièrement il y a pas beaucoup de
très bons connaisseurs de la carte
électorale mais j'ai un petit vice pour
ce sujet-là et donc on l'a fait avec les
gens qui savent de quoi il parl il n'y a
pas de cas où le RN a une majorité alors
sauf coup de théâtre exceptionnel s'il y
a 40 Crépol dans l'intervalle ou je ne
sais quoi qui change fondamentalement la
donne politique au mieux le RN serait le
premier des groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale
vraisemblablement coup de ton ce qui
serait un coup de tonner certainement
mais vraisemblablement avec moins de
voix que le cumul actuel horizon plus
modem plus Renaissance donc il serait à
la mercie du premier 493 venus parce que
les autres là en l'état et c'est ce que
disa berger il n'y a pas nécessairement
de MAJ enfin c'est pas qu'il y a pas
nécessairement il n'y a pas de majorité
alternative mais face au RN on peut
imaginer quand même qu'il y aurait une
incitation pour les autres partis à
verer un éventuel gouvernement pris dans
l'autre sens on risque de se retrouver
enfin moi je suis assez d'accord avec ce
que disait Mathieu tout à l'heure très
vraisemblablement ça sera une assemblée
qui ne serait pas plus gouvernable que
celle-là sauf sauf à se présenter dans
les électeurs dans le cadre d'un accord
de gouvernement vous faites une
coalition et Mame Macron n'a pas compris
que quand il y a pas de majorité absolue
pas de majorité possible dans le pays la
5è République n'est pas un régime
présidentiel mais un régime
parlementaire c'est peut-être TS qu'il
le contra on peut le faire avant ou
après le vote c'est il peut donner c'est
mieux avant ça marche mieux avant un
accord de gouvernement dans emande ça se
négocie souvent après donc alors je sais
bien c'est pas notre traditionou c'est
anticipé c'est anticipé quand même mais
mais bon on a bien compris que c'était
pas forcément l'avantage d'Emmanuel
Macron de de dissoudre l'Assemblée
nationale et encore c'est une Lite quand
je dis ça sauf que si ce qui s'est passé
lundi se reproduit fladio il y av un
moment où il y a un principe de réalité
si si c'est plus possible de faire
passer un seul texte ou de ou de de
faire examiner un texte je sais pas je
dis pas que ça va forcément se passer
mais il y aura cette tentation de
rééditer le coup politique de la part
que en l'espèce ça n'était pas n'importe
quel texte je sais euh ce texte là il
était quand même outré euh dans euh euh
les tout ce qu'il a il amené comme
divergence politique donc c'était le
texte sur lequel il y avait le moins de
de réunions possible moi je vois plutôt
une possibilité aussi où en réalité on
aura un filet d'eau tiède jusqu'à la fin
du quinquena en faisant passer quelques
petits textes de temps en temps et en
négociant au coup par coup en réalité
c'est ce qui s'est passé sur le début du
quinquena jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive à la
réforme des retraites h et aujet lo
immigration sont les deux éléments
traumatiques il y en a pas eu beaucoup
d'autres sur lesquels il y a eu une
maestria politique pour dépasser des
difficultés donc je crois que là très
clairement le président de la République
il sait ce qu'il peut faire ou ce qu'il
ne peut pas faire au regard de de l'épée
qu'il a dans le dos notamment depuis les
élection sénatorial alors il y a
effectivement des discussions alors qui
portent sur ce texte immigration
ellisabeth borne a repris la main
puisque les l refuse de discuter avec
Gérald darana donc elle a reçu les les
les les différents leaders euh du parti
euh LR aujourd'hui bis repétita demain
Christel est-ce qu'il y a parce que on
avait évoqué ça au début de ce second
quinquena l'hypothèse effectivement d'un
accord qui pourrait être un accord de
gouvernement entre Emmanuel Macron et et
et LR est-ce que c'est plus du tout à
l'ordre du jour
ça pour l'instant oui ça paraît
peut-être un peu compliqué par rapport à
la la la tension et la situation avec
ELR après la fin de l'histoire n'est pas
écrite effectivement donc il peut se
passer encore plein de choses donc à à
suivre mais voilà ça parait un peu un
prier ministre issu de
LR moi j'aime bien je des idées c'est
totalement
illuso en parl il ils en parlent en ce
moment mais chef oui c'est ça après il y
a deux choses le Premier ministre c'est
le chef de la majorité donc si vous
nommez quelqu'un de LR c'est pour qu'il
soit chef d'une majorité qui n'est pas
trouvable aujourd'hui mais qui pourrait
être trouvable demain généralement la
solution la plus simple c'est de passer
un accord d'appareil parce que il manque
40 députés à la macronie pour avoir la
majorité il y en a 60 chez LR c'est le
parti avec lequel il pourrait faire un
accord d'appareil LR s'il est toujours
refusé et puis les LR ont fait la preuve
de leur fiabilité cette année dès qu'il
faut crier ça turbine dès qu'il faut
voter ça se démine donc on voit c'est
pas toujours des partenaires très très
fiable après si vous n'avez pas d'accord
d'appareil vous pouvez essayer de
trouver une personnalité qui fera autour
de lui qui fera en gros quand une
autorité naturelle sur la droite pour et
alors là on voit commencer à paraître
des noms le nom du du locataire de ces
lieux le président du Sénat Gérard
Larché qui a longtemps été courtisé déjà
par Emmanuel Macron et qui peut faire
figure de valeur refuge à condition bien
sûr qu'il l'accepte ce qui est pas du
tout dit hein mais parce qu'on considère
que Gérard Larcher a une forme
d'autorité qui permettrait de de de de
raller des LR et puis un autre nom qui
circule qui circula en tout cas lundi
soir celui de françois Barouin par
exemple que qu'on croyait un peu en
retrait de la vie
politique parceon crédite utoré
naturelle mais qu'est-ce que ça voudrait
dire au fond ben ça voudrait dire qu'on
serait en cohabitation h parce qu'en
gros avec une figure de droite qui
permettrait de faire venir les voix qui
manquent à la macronie ben ça serait les
faisur de roi et Emmanuel Macron devrait
partager le pouvoir avec quelqu'un qu'il
aurait été contraint de choisir et donc
ça serait une forme de cohabitation qui
ne dirait pas son nom moi je crois que
la figure en question elle n'existe pas
en réalité parce que je ne pense pas que
Gérard Larché ou françois Barouin ou x
les LR sont très divisé regardez déjà la
droite sénatoriale n'a rien à voir puis
elle est capable de travailler avec
l'UDI ce qui est moins le cas quand même
à l'Assemblée national et je ne crois
pas que Gérard Larcher aurait avec lui
toute une partie des jeunes députés ou
des récents députés LR il faute il y a
aussi des sociologies électorales qui
jouent profondément à partir du moment
où il n'y a plus vraiment de logique
nationale et bah qu'est-ce qu'il emporte
la sociologie des circonscription
précise dont sont issu les députés et vu
que la droite n'a pas été capable de
définir un logiciel intellectuel ou
idéologique pas plus que la gauche
d'ailleurs mais depuis qu'Emmanuel
Macron est apparu il n'ont rien
reconstruit véritablement c'est quoi la
droite est-ce que c'est une droite plus
proeuropéenne plus libérale plus
conservatrice peut-être comme Bruno rot
est-ce que c'est la droite d'Aurélien
Pradier est-ce que c'est la droite d'éic
Coti qui est plus régalienne c'est quoi
la droite dans la mesure où eux-mêmes en
l'état ne sont pas capables de le
définir comment voudriez-vous qu'une
personnalité puisse s'imposer à eux par
sa simple autorité naturelle moi je je
crois que cette hypothèse là c'est
vraiment Emmanuel Macron qui ne comprend
pas la droite de la même manière que et
que Géral armanin lui a survendu sa
connaissance de la droite on a bien vu
que non ce qui se passait en sou-terrain
c'était pas exactement ce qu'il en
percevait lui merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat et à
bientôt sur sur Public Sénat